this is representative
aoc alexandria ocasio-cortez who showed
up to the met gala one of the most
preposterous frilly silly events of the
year where people wear lots of silly
sorts of outfits and they pay upwards of
30 000 a ticket and they go hobnob with
very rich people
so aoc shows up and she gets the
attention she craves and she wears a
dress that says on the back of it tacks
the rich
right over her uh derriere you see it's
not on the front it's on the back tax
the rich and she coquetially looks over
her shoulder ah yes that'll show the man
she shows up to this very fancy event
that says tax the rich right so p
everyone's focusing on the hypocrisy
this is a wealthy woman who's showing up
to a lavish party with all of her
extraordinarily wealthy friends and she
says tax the rich right and that's this
is hypocritical sure but more offensive
to me than the hypocrisy is the
frivolity of it all
we are supposed to believe
that
this clown show this bread in circuses
actually defines our politics oh aoc
that'll she'll show them it's aoc versus
the republicans oh
who's gonna win oh oh did you see what
aoc tweeted oh did you see what
so-and-so tweeted today
in fact it's it's just a performance
whatever this woman does some other
silly woman showed up and said equal
rights for women you know at this at the
most establishment of the
establishmentarian establishmentarian
events of the year
this has very little to do with the way
we're actually governed
it this is a sideshow this is a circus
to keep us all entertained so we root
for aoc or we root against aoc and we
all jibber jabber about the dresses
the the way our government is actually
run is that some bureaucrat that you've
never heard of at
like osha or at one of the alphabet
agencies in washington dc just write
some regulation that you're almost
certainly never going to hear about and
then that's going to have effects down
the line on some business and it's going
to change the way that you interact with
society it's going to change the way the
economy is run and and if you're not
even going to notice it because you're
going to be focused on aoc's stupid
dress to me that's what so for us it's
so disrespectful not that aos i mean
it's disrespectful that aoc is
pretending to be this people's champion
when she is the darling of the
establishment at the met gala 30 000 a
ticket but it's it's more offensive the
lack of respect that these people in
general have for
the voters for the american people
who are being denied our
political rights or being deprived of
our way of life who can't even have
faith in the integrity of our elections
but boy do we have a good sideshow
when's the last time you think you had
american meat chances are
it's been
way too long much longer than you
believe that you did did you know that
over 80 percent of the grass-fed beef
sold in the u.s is imported from
overseas my friends the good ranchers
have traveled the country on a mission
to help the american family by working
together with local farms and ranches
and shipping straight to your door
goodranchers.com delivers american craft
beef and better than organic chicken
they've got t-bones filets strips
gourmet burgers and more and at half the
price of online competitors you get the
steakhouse quality you deserve at a
price every family can afford go to
goodranchers.com right now and you can
save 20 bucks or better yet subscribe
and save on each box of mouth-watering
american meats that will show up right
on schedule right to your door i love it
especially the burgers strongly
recommend the burgers they're very juicy
very delicious right now get 20 bucks
off and free express shipping if you go
to goodranchers.com
or use code knowles at checkout 20 bucks
off free express shipping at
goodranchers.com
knowles
the other
strange thing not strange if you've been
paying attention
about the met gala
is that none of the people were wearing
masks aoc wasn't wearing a mask
some other lady i don't know i don't
know a lot of these rich fancy new york
society types a lot of famous
politicians and actors and actresses
there none of them were wearing masks
actually the only people who were
wearing masks were the help
it was the staff
all the staff that were waiting on the
celebrities hand and foot they had to
wear masks to keep their filth away from
the good clean beautiful famous people
the ruling class
they don't want to get those nasty icky
germs from the yucky help
so the help wears the masks
the
anointed ones don't have to wear the
masks even though we're living
is it still the delta that's surging
allegedly or is it the lambda now or is
it the sigma what is it
is it it's the 15th data slow the spread
or it's the 570th data i don't i don't
quite remember all i know is you filthy
pigs need to keep your masks on to keep
your yucky breath and germs away from us
beautiful anointed people tax the rich
text the we're gonna show them
power to the people
what a joke what a joke what a bunch of
clowns i mean they dr they actually
dressed up like clowns
and then they put on a big circus and
and by the way we fell for it we're all
talking about it
we sort of have to talk about it but if
if i must talk about it
i i do not want to talk about it from
the shallow perspective
that the ruling class wants us to
i at least want to lift back that
curtain i think so much
of the past four or five years has been
about pulling back
that curtain
i'm so glad that you enjoyed that clip i
want you to enjoy the whole show so head
on over to
the michael knowles show at apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
head up before you go vote again in
california i assume you've already voted
once before someone voted for you
but before you go do it again subscribe
to the michael knowles show we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]